اصدرت المحكمه العليا الامريكيه قرارين
رفضت فيهما دعاوى قضائيه تسعى الى تحميل
عمالقه تكنولوجيا مثل جوجل وتويتر
المسؤوليه عن محتوى يروج للارهاب على
منصاتهم وتعد هذه هي المره الاولى التي
تتعامل فيها المحكمه العليا مع البند 230
من قانون اداب الاتصالات وهو قانون عام
1996 الذي يحمي شركات التكنولوجي على نطاق
واسع من المقاضات على خلفيه استضافه محتوى
الجهات الخارجيه على منصاتها وقرارات
ازاله المواد المخالفه
ويشكل قرار المحكمه العليا فوزا كبيرا
لشركات التكنولوجيا التي جادلت بان تضييق
230 قد يكون كارثيا على الانترنت غير ان
القرار يترك الباب مفتوحا امام الجدل
الحزب في الكوندرس حول نطاق الحمايه
القانونيه التي تتمتع بها شركات الانترنت